nobody wants to destroy the world let me
ask you a tough question so
you
are very likely to be one of not the
person that creates AGI
one up one of and even then like we're
on a team of many there will be many
teams but several small number of people
nevertheless relative
I do think it's strange that it's maybe
a few tens of thousands of people in the
world
a few thousands play in the world but
there will be a room
with a few folks who are like holy
that happens more often than you would
think now I understand I understand this
I understand this but yes there will be
more such rooms which is a beautiful
place to be in the world uh terrifying
but mostly beautiful uh so that might
make you and a handful of folks
uh the most powerful humans on Earth
do you worry that power might corrupt
you
for sure
um look I don't
I think
you want
decisions about this technology and
certainly decisions about
who is running this technology to become
increasingly Democratic over time we
haven't figured out quite how to do this
um but we part of the reason for
deploying like this is to get the world
to have time to adapt yeah and to
reflect and to think about this to pass
regulation for our institutions to come
up with new norms for the people working
out together like that is a huge part of
why we deploy
even though many of the AI safety people
you referenced earlier think it's really
bad even they acknowledge that this is
like of some benefit
um
but I think any version of one person is
in control
of this is really bad
so trying to distribute the power supply
I don't have and I don't want like any
like super voting power or any special
like then you know I know like control
of the board or anything like that above
an AI yeah
but AGI if created has a lot of power
how do you think we're doing like honest
how do you think we're doing so far like
how do you think our decisions are like
do you think we're making things not
better or worse what can we do better
well the things I really like because I
know a lot of folks at open AI the thing
I really like is the transparency
everything you're saying which is like
failing publicly
writing papers releasing different kinds
of
information about the safety concerns
involved
doing it out in the open
is great
because especially in contrast to some
other companies that are not doing that
they're being more closed
that said you could be more open do you
think we should open source GPT for
my personal opinion because I know
people at open AI is no
what is knowing the people at open AI
have to do with it because I know
they're good people I know a lot of
people I know they're good human beings
from a perspective of people that don't
know the human beings there's a concern
it was a super powerful technology in
the hands of a few that's closed it's
closed in some sense but we give more
access to it yeah than like if this had
just been Google's game
I I feel it's very unlikely that anyone
would have put this API out there's PR
risk with it yeah like I get personal
threats because of it all the time I
think most companies wouldn't have done
this so maybe we didn't go as open as
people wanted but like we've distributed
it pretty broadly you personally an open
ai's culture is not so like nervous
about uh PR risk and all that kind of
stuff you're more nervous about the risk
of the actual technology and you've and
you reveal that so I you know the
nervousness that people have is because
it's such early days of the technology
is that you will close off over time
because more and more powerful my
nervousness is you get attacked so much
by fear mongering clickbait journalism
they're like why the hell do I need to
deal with this I think the clickbait
journalism bothers you more than it
bothers me
no I'm uh third person bothered like I
appreciate that like I feel all right
about it of all the things I lose sleep
over it's not high on the list because
it's important there's a handful of
companies a handful of folks that are
really pushing this forward they're
amazing folks and I don't want them to
become cynical about the rest uh the
rest of the world I think people at open
AI feel the weight of responsibility of
what we're doing and yeah it would be
nice if like you know journalists were
nicer to us and Twitter trolls gave us
more benefit of the doubt but like
I think we have a lot of resolve in what
we're doing and why
and the importance of it
but I really would love and I ask this
like of a lot of people not just if
cameras rolling like any feedback you've
got for how we can be doing better we're
in uncharted waters here talking to
smart people is how we figure out what
to do better uh how do you take feedback
do you take feedback from Twitter also
do because does the sea the watch
Twitter is unreadable yeah
so sometimes I do I can like take a
sample a cup out of the waterfall
um but I mostly take it from
conversations like this